and you are actually the first foreign
leader that I've had the privilege of
welcoming here as prime minister and
there's a lot of great history here in
fact this room that we're standing in
Winston Churchill made many of his
famous speeches in World War II from
this run and in the same way today your
leadership your country's bravery and
fortitude are an inspiration to us or I
look forward to us discussing what more
we can do to support you and your
country
first of all thank you very much you're
supported already a lot for us you did a
lot to you your government and His
Majesty the king and of course your
people your Society where we're thankful
from all our hearts from ukrainians from
our soldiers we are thankful and this
privilege to be here yes the first time
you said not the last definitely not the
last so we'll of course we'll we'll
discuss very important issues urgent
support for Ukraine and security for I
think not only for Ukraine it's about
for all the Europe so thank you thank
you that you hosting me and invited me
well it's great to have you here my
friend thanks for being here thank you
everyone thank you